ich bin sehr wütend ja also wir stellen
sich einfach zwei fragen meine
großmutter ist ein 90 ein dass sie noch
nicht geimpft war und wie kann es sein
dass sie sich im krankenhaus mit group
19 anschlägt also da ist ganz
offensichtlich was er falsch gelaufen
und in diesen krassen kontrast was ich
hier in israel erlebe wenn ich das
einfach unfassbar was ich für
nachrichten aus solchen akteure und
leser auch von kollegen und freunden die
alte eltern oder großeltern haben pro
kind die bundeskanzlerin hat zum corona
tod alter menschen in heime diese woche
auch gesagt es bricht mir das herz
ist das ein trost für sie ja das ist
jetzt kein trost für mich es geht mir
jetzt auch nicht darum direkt die
kanzlerin anzuklagen aber ist das ja ein
ganz einfache frage die eine sache ist
dass man nicht genug impfstoff hat das
ist ein komplexer sachverhalt da würde
ich mit sich eines konkret beurteilen zu
können
die andere sache ist warum man den
impfstoff den mann hat nicht effektiv
erteilt bekommt und ich erlebe dass hier
in impfzentren war ich habe mit menschen
gesprochen die werden dann alte leute ja
am kz überlebende zuteil
sie werden dann teilweise persönlich
angerufen und her gebeten
zum impfen und das geht innerhalb von
zehn minuten dann ließ sich irgendwie
aus deutschland oder höre dass die 89
jährige mutter eines bekannten in
brandenburg selber aus den nachrichten
aus dem radio in liegen muss das jetzt
dran ist dann noch hotline anrufen soll
wie sie tagelang nicht erreicht und dann
gibt es in ganz brandenburg zwei
impfzentren die weit weg sind wir alle
wissen wie gut die infrastruktur an
druck ist wie soll die 98 jährige dahin
kommen also das sind alles sachen die
machen mich fassungslos von mir aus